8 news now reporter madison kimbrough
spoke with parents and kids at that park
today
she joins us live from the newsroom with
the very latest madison
yes this was an act of arson as the
reunion trails park playground was set
on fire new year's eve
leaving at least a hundred thousand
dollars in damage
some kids like really enjoy this this
part of the parks and some kids
maybe not as much but for all the other
kids that actually do enjoy it
it's really discouraging for all of them
to see that their favorite
favorite part about the playground is
now destroyed
a favorite hangout spot for several kids
and their parents
part of the reunion trails park
playground was set on fire
new year's eve night after security
footage shows three people
walking on the premises with a
flashlight at the time of the crime
by new year's day the damage had set in
we came yesterday afternoon
and that's the first thing we saw we saw
all the
caution tape around it and the fence and
we just started asking questions around
to give you all an overview of what the
park usually looks like
this 12-acre recreational area has a
splash pad
and a walking course basketball court
and playground
but now the playground structure
surfacing shade canopy
and women's restroom are all destroyed
it's very disappointing you know
henderson is great because it has so
many parks
but this one is really special because
you have a great view great equipment
equipment that will now have to be
replaced over time and henderson police
department
estimates that it will cost at least a
hundred thousand dollars
if not more to fix the damage done
and henderson police is asking anyone
with information to call crime stoppers
immediately reporting live in the
newsroom madison kimbrough 8 news now